good afternoon good evening and welcome
everyone
we want to thank you for joining us for
our presentation titled
automated sample preparation for
biopharmaceutical analysis
removing inefficiencies and variability
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
kenda evans
a field application scientist with
agilent technologies
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
that
and submit them in the q a box our
speaker will address your questions
following the presentation
please join me in welcoming dr evans i
will now turn the presentation
over to her thank you so much i
appreciate that introduction and thank
you everyone for attending today
so as i mentioned i am kenda evans i
am a product specialist for the
automation division for agilent
and today we're going to be talking
about the assay
map bravo and how it can be used
for automated sample prep so going
through the
agenda for today's talk i'm going to
talk a little bit about the
technology i'm going to talk about the
workbench or the software
and some of the different types of
applications that can be done
on a single platform for the assay matt
bravo
affinity purification in-solution
digestion
peptide protein cleanup phosphopeptide
enrichment
on cartridge enzymatic reactions and in
glycan analysis
so you really get a broad range of
different things that can be done
throughout an entire workflow as well as
individual little components that can be
done on
your samples
so what is kind of the workflow that
we're kind of discussing here
well we have our sample prep in front
and that's the assay map bravo and you
can see this in the picture
that we have on the far left hand side
and then
agilent has the full continuum so you
can do your sample prep with the assay
map bravo
then your separation and detection with
our lcms products
as well as the data processing with all
of our different types of software
that are available right now
so what exactly is the assay map
technology
so this is an actual automated workflow
that's designed for analytical chemists
we wanted to make sure that this was
something that would be easy to be used
by folks that aren't automation um
experts and they don't have to be an
automation guru that learn knows how to
program something
that's one of the worst things about
getting automation in the lab is people
are scared to use it because
the programming language is difficult to
learn or
it just takes a lot of time so we've
tried to eliminate those
obstacles so that you can get in and
start using this technology
almost immediately so with the assay map
technology there are several different
components
we have micro cartridges and these are
for
um quantitative binding and illusion
basically we have different flavors of
the
cartridges and you'll see this in the
list we have affinity purification so
protein a
protein g and then streptavidin for your
biotinylated
antibodies or biotinylated routines we
have
reverse phase cleanup using our c18
and rps rps stands for reverse phase
small bore cartridges and the rpw
is reverse phase wide bore for doing
more of the protein or
denatured antibody type of cleanup
we can do fractionation with our strong
cation exchange as well as our
different reverse phase cartridges and
then phosphor
peptide enrichment with titanium dioxide
as well as
iron nta the iron nta
cartridge is an imac cartridge so you're
able to cleave off
that iron heavy metal and replace it
with a different heavy metal
if need be to look at different tagged
type of um proteins and peptides
we also can use motif antibodies using
our protein a
protein g or streptavidin if there's a
specific
type of antibody raised against
a phosphopeptide serine 143
and you wanted really to pull out only
phosphopeptide serine 143
you would be able to do that if you have
a strong antibody that's raised against
that
we also now have higher capacity
cartridges
we have just released protein a and
streptavidin they have the astro
guide theme and rps and c18 are on their
way
unfortunately due to the unprecedented
covid19
pandemic the release of the rps and c18
has been a bit
delayed but it is coming soon
so that is in the picture at the top you
will see
both the different kind of cartridges
that we have our standard
5 microliter resin as well as our higher
capacity
25 microliter resin
so we also have a specific
way that we're doing this and the head
gas a map bravo
is built just a little bit differently
so that it can actually
work with these microchromatography
cartridges and it is a positive
displacement pipettor
so the syringes inside the head
there's 96 syringes all at once and i'll
tell you a little bit more about those
in
our next slide but they work directly
with the cartridges
and enable a precise controlled liquid
flow through the cartridges
so you don't have any air bubbles you
don't have any disruption of the binding
so you can control the flow rate
so if you think of the head and the
syringes
like the pump and the cartridges like
your
column you'll see why we're considering
this micro chromatography
type of technology
we also have very simple user interface
it's
in a gui form base so basically what you
need to do
is open up the application of interest
then
tell it the different parameters how
many um
samples you're going to be working with
you can do anywhere from
one to 96 samples at the same time
and then the volumes that you want to
work with you can also control the flow
rates if you need to
slow them down or speed them up and then
basically
set up the deck the way that it is
described in the pictorial
and press the green button to say go
it's literally that
simple to get up and running with the
assay map bravo
so here's an up close picture of the
actual
bravo assay matt bravo head you can see
that there are 96
syringes those are the kind of a beige
things that are sticking down from the
head in the upper left hand corner in
the lower
left hand corner you'll see that we have
four columns of cartridges that are
loaded
onto the four columns of the
assaymat bravo head this is the way of
us being able to do
different types of numbers of samples at
a time
so we recommend doing a full column of
cartridges
on throughout the workflow but as i
mentioned you can do from 1
to 96 samples throughout your workflows
the nice thing about using the
cartridges as well as the syringes
is that you can aspirate up through the
cartridge
you can dispense down through the
cartridge you can actually aspirate in
dispense
using just the syringe or the probe and
then you can also use a
bravo pipette tip on the syringe probe
to be able to aspirate and dispense as
well in some of our liquid handling
utilities that we've developed
in the lower right hand corner you
actually see what that syringe
looks like so the kind of beigey part
is a very chemical resistant peak
plastic
with very high quality chemical
resistant glass
at the top and then they see the syringe
plunger
is and has kind of a teflon coating at
the very end of the plunger and that
fits inside the actual
syringe there's one piston inside
the head that is at that is moving all
96
of the syringes at once so they're not
independently controlled
but because we're able to have the
reagents
in columns in our reagent plates or have
our cartridges in columns on the head
that's a way that we can actually do
a different numbers other than the full
head of 96
all at once so in the applications that
i mentioned there's a lot of different
things that you can do
as i mentioned antibody purification
amino affinity
purification peptide and protein cleanup
the protein digestion
on cartridge reaction is one of our
newer protocols
fractionation in glycan sample prep as
well as phosphopeptide
enrichment and i'm going to go through
each of these in a little more detail
the large capacity affinity cartridges
as we've just
released these i want to make sure that
i kind of
describe why we thought that these were
important as well
the original cartridges that we released
are five
microliter resin bed and the
like for protein a that has a binding
capacity of about a hundred micrograms
but if you're doing things such as
bioprocessing or things like that that
you really need
a lot more binding capacity to enhance
for the sample that you're trying to
pull out of your solution
you needed a larger binding capacity so
that is why we've created the higher
capacity cartridges
to allow for that higher
um binding capacity of being able to
really
get much more out of your sample
you're going to still be able to do your
peptide mapping your peptide quant your
post-translational modifications
as well as look at intact and fragments
and functional assays and protein
aggregations those are just some of the
different types of applications that
these
cartridges and this technology is being
used for out in the field
so what else can you use these for well
proteomics is another
great place for being able to utilize
these
using our c18 and our rps cartridges
once they're going to be available
to be able to really clean up a large
amount of the sample that you're looking
at for
doing either untargeted proteomics or
your targeted proteomics so there's
lots of different things that where you
just need larger binding capacity and
you just need to get a much
higher enrichment and that's why these
large capacity cartridges are now so
exciting that we can
release those out into the field
so now i mean jump into a little bit
more of our software just because i
mentioned that you don't have to be an
automation engineer to be able to use
our software
and i wanted to kind of show you how we
have set it up
so we have a little ambulance spark on
the desktop of the computer that
controls the assaymap bravo
and that brings you to our protein
sample workbench
and within the workbench you have
choices of four different options a
workflow library an
application library utility library or
the literature library
any one of those would then open up into
the different types of libraries
that we have in those different
tabs so looking at the application
library this is just a sampling of
all the different types of applications
that are available
we have them all color coded as well as
in alphanumeric
order and some people really like just
to find oh i know i'm doing the yellow
protocol today or i'm doing in solution
digestion so
they they know where to go to look for
their application if they want to do
that
as we release new applications
we usually have the older applications
that are superseded by the new ones if
we've made
updates or if we've changed some of the
parameters or things like that
and so we have the ones that are about
to be obsoleted
just because there are older models in
the gray
at the end of our application menu
letting you know that you know if you're
starting a new project start off with
the newer protocols
and it also gives people time if they've
already created sops or they've been
working with some of our older protocols
they have time to continue to validate
and make sure that the newer ones
are haven't changed enough that they're
causing any kind of disruption
in their workflows so we allow for that
type of
standardization as well as continuity
between protocols
in the utility library i always like to
think of the utility library as things
that you would do before
or after you're doing your actual
chemistry
so utility libraries are going to be
things that you're doing
like reagent transfers this is a liquid
handler
and we really wanted to make sure that
we were able to utilize it for all that
it could do and there's so many things
that the assay map bravo can actually do
so the utilities allow for creating
reagent plates
doing serial dilution doing reformatting
or cherry picking if you have some
compounds in a plate that you want to
have outside
in a different order you can reformat
them if you wanted to do normalization
so you have your your actual set of
samples
and you see that they have their
concentrations
all over the place and before you move
downstream
before you go into your say your
glycoprep and before you're looking at
your glycans
you want to make sure that you have a
hundred microliters
of one meg per ml of your sample that
you're going forward in just to have
everything as standardized as possible
you can do a normalization with the
assay map bravo and it's very simple to
set up
you basically will tell the assaymat
bravo some numbers about what your
samples are
and then what you want them to be and
it'll go through and
sample by sample by sample pick up a
single sample at a time
and add the number of the volume of the
sample that you need
as well as the volume of the diluent
that you need until you've actually
normalized the entire plate of samples
that you've requested
so i've actually had some researchers
that have wanted to purchase the essay
matt bravo
solely to use the normalization protocol
so they use it for other things but that
was
that was a key driver that they really
really were excited about being able to
use their normalization protocol
so when you're looking at the
application this is just
a actual um screenshot of our affinity
purification
application and they are very harmonized
so
you if once you start working with one
you'll be able to really
see how they look with looking at the
other ones
this is just the example of affinity
purification
we have the ability of actually saving a
method
so i can say that this is kenda's
affinity purification
2.0 or whatever i want to call my
methods
and then that's actually going to be in
a file folder on the computer
that i would be able to load so i don't
have to
recreate the same protocol over and over
and over again if i'm doing basically
the same parameters every single time
so i would actually load my method that
i have had saved
i would tell it how many full columns of
cartridges
i want to be able to use today and once
i click on that
load up at the top in the yellow box
it'll actually populate all the numbers
that are within the protocol so it'll
have all my
flow rates it'll have all my volumes
it'll have
all of my wash station uh parameters as
well
now on the deck of the bravo we do have
a wash station
and that is bean float it's a chimney
style wash station so we actually have
a di water or millicue water that's
going through this
the chimneys in the wash station so that
we can
constantly clean the probes
after we do each one of our additions so
you'll
see here in the in the line of the
protocol
we have the the priming and at the end
it says
wash number and that's actually the head
coming over into the wash station to
actually do
the washes of the head to make sure that
we're not transferring reagents or
transferring
any type of samples into our next step
we also have a peltier so i told you
earlier that we could do in solution
digestion
well we want to make sure that we keep
our
reagents at a certain temperature and so
we'll be able to use our peltier in
our in solution digestion as well as our
on cartridge reaction as well as our
glycam protocols so there's a lot of
different things that we have
on deck that enable us to do all the
different workflows that we've talked
about
it's very easy for a bench scientist to
be able to pick it up and go
right into working on the assay map
bravo
the benefits are that's very minimal
training
is needed i can basically you know work
with the lab and get them up and running
and they
can be off to the races in the next day
or two we usually have two days of
training and people are ready to go
very rapid implementation so you can get
up and going
quickly already have kind of a optimized
protocol just by our defaults
and if you're collaborating with other
labs outside
of your institution across the state
across the country across the pond
you'll be able to actually transfer the
protocols just because
everything is harmonized and you'll be
able to see exactly what your
collaborators are doing
as well so it makes it very simple to
work with
this is what people don't like to see
this is under the hood this is what is v
works and that's actually driving
everything so this is what we've taken
away
from having the end users have to work
with
um and i'm going to get off of this
really quick because that scares a lot
of people so i don't want you all to
think that you have to look at that
so now i'm actually going to dive into
more of the workflows
the first one that i'm going to talk
about is affinity purification and this
is using our protein ar protein g
cartridges and this is very simple it's
bind
wash elute you can use up to
a mill of your samples we want to make
sure that
it's particulate free so you don't bind
up and clog up the fritz
that are in the cartridges and you can
do
use up to a full plate or 96
samples can be done you can actually
elute in as small as 10 microliters so
if you're using a mill of your sample
and you elute in
as little as 10 microliters you've
actually had a hundred
fold concentration or an enhancement of
your sample
so now you have a highly purified
antibody it's an
aqueous buffer and then you can take
that and put it on
downstream workflows so if you needed to
take it right from there you can do
whatever you need to
with it but it's going to be a very a
very clean system at that point
but this is a little more of the data
this is looking at our smaller capacity
our five microliter bed volume
um binding capacities for these
cartridges
and this is actually if you look at the
gray inset
on the right hand side this is actually
looking at the very
lowest amount that we're binding to
our protein a and protein g cartridges
using human igg spiked into chinese
hamster ovary cell culture supernatant
you can see that we have very good
recovery and we're able to really have
very strong binding at very
low levels so what you're putting in
you're basically getting out
90 of the loaded mass for every
cartridge
actually was able to be recovered so
very strong
recovery very tight reproducibility
and this is an example of actually being
able to elute
everything in a very small amount so you
can see with our protein a and our
protein g
cartridges we're actually able to elute
close to 98 percent of
all of the sample that we put in
in less than 10 microliters so the first
two microliters is going to be
kind of the dead volume and then the
rest is going to be
our sample that we're pulling out
with streptavidin of course you can use
strepto avenue cartridges just like
you've used streptavidin for any other
ways make sure that you can have a
biotinylated
antibody you could incubate your
antibody and your antigen together
or you could have a biotinylated antigen
so
we haven't created anything new we've
just created a new tool to be able to
use our biotinylated antibodies
so in solution digestion is another
thing that we're able to do
on the deck of the assay map bravo
so you would put in your sample you
would do your denaturant your reductant
and your alkalete and then be able to
have everything digested
and after you've added your protease
and then you can actually do your
cleanup to get rid of all the salt so
that you actually have
a nice sample clean
sample of your peptides that then you're
able to put in your lcms to be able to
do your separation
and your analysis
so for in solution digestion again it's
very straightforward
you can have your particulate free
solutions we actually have a protocol
that will allow you to do digestion on
up to
four 96 well plates so if you had the
need
to digest 384 samples all at once
we have that capability of being able to
do it
we've also created a more
simplified one plate type of
in solution digestion protocol that
allows for the addition
of up to four reagents into a single
sample plate and so that protocol can
really be
repurposed if you will for many
different types of protocols
when you needed to add up to four
different reagents into the same
sample plate and potentially have
incubation steps
as well so there's lots of different
ways you can utilize
our protocols what you're going to get
out
of the of the in solution digestion is
going to be
your peptides and then that's going to
be ready for your peptide
cleanup so in doing the peptide cleanup
you're going to be able to have either
the c18
which is a silica based or our rps
as i mentioned that's a small bore
polymeric type of reverse phase
cartridge
again it's bind wash elute hopefully you
see a pattern
you want the particulate free type of
solution
to be used with here you can use up to a
mill
of your sample and you can work with up
to 96 samples at a time
you can still get up to that 100 fold
concentration factor because again we
can elute in as small as
10 microliters off of our small capacity
card
so in peptide cleanup it should look
very similar to what i showed you
previously with the affinity
purification
type of protocol so this allows you to
choose
all of this one already has all the
numbers the default
numbers in it so you actually have the
ability to conduct a step with a check
mark that's in this first column
and then you change volumes as needed
you change the flow rates
as needed and then the number of times
it's going to go into the wash station
you have the ability to choose from from
pre-configured
types of labware that we recommend and
that we've already defined
and then as long as you put it
everything on the deck
as we have defined in the pictorial for
the deck layout
all you need to do is come over and hit
the green button
at the top on the right hand side that
says run
peptide cleanup and you'll be able to
come back in about 45 to 50 minutes if
you're using our five microliter
reverse phase cartridges and be able and
some of the default
settings that we have here and you would
be able to have your clean
salt free peptides ready to go on for
analysis
this is just some of the data this is
looking at
bsa what we did was bsa digestion and
then
also clean up one day we worked with
it using urea as our denaturant the
other day we used
guanidine and we also cleaned it up
with either c18 or with rps
so a lot of folks ask us well which one
is the better one to use
and we in this app note we really showed
that they're very very comparable
between
the rps and the c18 and using
either urea or guanidine for your dna
as you can see that the percent cvs are
very very low
for the five peptides that we have
listed here and in the table down below
you can see
how many different samples that we were
testing
and how many we monitored and also the
types
of percent cvs that were less than five
percent
that were in between five and ten
percent and that was greater
than ten percent so very very tight cvs
that were getting very reproducible and
very clean
data comparing the difference between
rps
and c18 for the cleanup
another example of that is when we were
working with
a map looking at quantitation
these peaks are actually 12
different samples that are actually
lined up on top of each other so we
actually have a
very good reproducibility again you see
the different peptides
and their percent cv so all of this was
less than eight percent
percent cv that's the highest one that
we have in this table
but again this goes to show the
different types of
reduction in your variability in the
increase in your recovery rates that
we're able to show
with this technology
so with this you can actually do as i've
shown already
many different things you can go with
your complete
workflow if you have an antibody from
the very start you can purify it then
you're going to have your purified
antibody
you can digest it you can clean clean it
up so it's now going to be salt free
peptides
and then you can be able to use that on
the lcms
to really see very quality data
as you're using your high sensitive
lcms you want to make sure that you're
only looking at the a clean
sample you don't want to be analyzing
things that you don't you don't care
about
so the more enhancement that you can do
and the cleaner the sample the better
the results at the other end
looking at it as in another way it's
also great for
doing different types of um
identification if you want to really
look at peptide mapping and you want to
use different types
of proteases you can do that all in the
same run so you don't have the
variability of when i did it this time i
used
trypsin when i did it this time i use
glue c
hopefully that looks all the same and i
did everything exactly the same
time you can actually put the different
proteases in a column in our reagent
plates and run the same samples
at the same time through the entire
protocol and then you would be able to
see
what it looks like if you have all those
different types of peptide mappings
and an example of that is here when
we're actually looking at the different
types of amino acid coverage
that we were able to get if we had
trypsin chemotrypsin or gluc
you can see for the light chain we had
basically 100
of our amino acid coverage and for the
heavy chain
we had 99 so we're really
able to map out the map
very very uniquely
so if you also wanted to do rapid
antibody digestion because one of the
biggest things about your digestion
protocol
is that the denaturant in the in
solution digestion
slows down your protease so there's a
lot of new proteases that are quick
acting and high temperature and
everything like that
but you want to still make sure that the
denaturant that you have in your
solution is as low as possible so that
protease has
as much umph as possible so we have the
ability of actually using
protein cleanup using our reverse
phase wide bore cartridges or our rpw
cartridges to be able to remove the
denaturant
after we've done our denaturant
reductant and alkylation
we'll clean up everything get rid of
that denaturant and then we're able to
add our protease
to be able to really speed up that
digestion
and this allows us to in this case this
application note we had a
protease or a trypsin digestion of only
two hours
and we were able to still get really
great data
in looking at our peptide mapping or
doing quantification or
post-translational modifications
and this is just some of that data that
we had
the first thing that we looked at is our
dynamic binding
with that because we're working with
proteins here so it's the dynamic
binding capacity is going to be a little
bit different than if we were working
with peptides
but we were able to show with our rpw
cartridges
that we start seeing the breakthrough of
the eluit
about 75 micrograms so that's what we
consider as
our dynamic binding capacity we're still
able to elute off
basically 98 of everything that we put
in
within 10 microliters if we're using our
five microliter
bed cartridges and then this is just
looking at
over a series of different
samples the reproducibility at the
different
at the different um load amount so 10
micrograms
25 50 and 75 you see that we're really
able to well in fact we've made mass
because our percent recovery is actually
over a hundred
but we're actually able to recover up to
100 percent
and we're actually able to have very
very tight cds so excellent recovery as
well as
very tight data and reproducibility
now if we're working with phosphopeptide
enrichment
again we're going to be using bind
washing a loot
this is just an example of us being able
to use our iron
nta or our imac cartridges
to pull out our specific
phosphopeptide um to do phosphopeptide
enrichment
the phosphopeptide enrichment is there's
some folks there are some phospho
peptides that really respond
well to iron mta or imac type cartridges
and there's some phosphopeptides and
some phosphopeptide researchers
that really like titanium dioxide so we
have both
options because we want to make sure
that you're able to get the most
of your phosphopeptides out of your
system and be able to use those in your
downstream
reagent our downstream analysis
this is looking at alpha casein alpha
casein is just a really good
highly phosphorylated type of
reagent that's good to use as a model
system so what we've done
is we've shown the sample input of what
we're
kind of putting in there and then we
also have our cartridge
eluit so what we're actually pulling out
and then our our excuse me our flow
through
which is anything that didn't bind to
our
phosphopeptide enriching cartridge
and then we actually have our specific
phosphopeptides that we're able to pull
out
and in here you can see the little peaks
that we have and then the asterisks that
are above
are whether that was a singly
phosphorylated a double
phosphorylated or even a triple
phosphorylated peptide
and we're able to have a lot of those
pulled
out of the sample and be able to have
very good identification
of all of those different types of
phosphopeptides
from the case alpha casein samples
now phosphopeptide enrichment as i
mentioned it's still that bind wash
any loot so if you're using the iron nta
if you're using the titanium dioxide or
as i mentioned
originally in the beginning of the
product of the presentation
you can use motif antibodies and
cst has actually had a paper on this
previously about using specific
motif antibodies to really enhance that
enrichment
even greater than just kind of the
generic phosphopeptide enrichment that
you would get with titanium dioxide
or with iron nta
so another way of being able to use the
assay map bravo
is to look at kind of accurate mass
and we're doing that with our on
cartridge reaction
protocols so what we would do is we
would immobilize
our in this case a vibrated antigen
and then we would enrich for the mab
that actually
bound to that antigen so now we have
our antigen and we have our antibody
that is kind of immobilized onto our
cartridges
if we don't use any enzyme at all and we
elute
we could actually get off the intact map
or
have if we're having under reduction
conditions
we could have the heavy chain and the
light chain
another way of being able to utilize
this tool and
look at things is if you're using on
cartridge d glycosylation
so if we actually use a um
the uh the glycosylator and be able to
use pro
the oh geez i just went blank on the
name of it anyway
if we're cleaning off all of our glycans
we would be able to collect
all of those in our flow through and
then be able to use the instant pc kit
or our prozone kits and be able to look
at all the glycans that we've cleaved
off
and then we can also have our d
glycosylated
intact mab or again if it's under
reducing conditions
we would have our d-glycosylated heavy
chain and light chain
another way of being able to utilize
this
is if we're actually going to break up
the map say we want to use ideas or a
fabricator
we can actually cleave the antibody at
the hinge region
and be able to have just the fc portion
that would come
off after the enzymatic reaction of the
ideas
and then be able to elute off either the
fab section or the fd in the light chain
section
of the map so another way of really
being able to look at the different
components of your antibody if needed
this enables quite a few different
workflows
so being able to look at drug to
antibody ratio
or antibody drug conjugates looking at
intact
protein accurate mass with the glycans
or without
looking at different post-translational
modifications as well as doing glycan
profiling and identification
so lots of different ways of being able
to use the on cartridge reaction
to be able to enable for more
information
about your sample
we also have our our prozyn folks that
are now part of agilent which we're
really excited about
we can actually have the glycoprep
protocols that
prozyme created they're made
specifically for the assay map and these
are already
programmed into the assay map bravo so
when you are originally doing glycans
and i know it's very tedious if you're
doing this by hand
that have to use the microfuse cubes and
centrifuge and everything it takes about
four to five hours
to do about 24 and so that's with a
really good
person in the lab that's very
conscientious but we all know that when
you're doing things manually there's
always that person that walks in the lab
and asks that question right as you're
about to
add some crucial reagent so it could
always
take um reduce the amount of samples
just because you want to make sure that
you don't get your
your carpal tunnel and your fatigue and
you don't make those mistakes
you can also do it in a plate based
format if you do it in the plate based
format it's still going to be being done
manually you have to watch it as you're
doing it you so you can be there for the
next step to add the next set of
reagents
and you're still being having to use a
centrifuge so it takes a little bit more
time or it takes about four to five
hours
but it takes your time because you have
to be there
in the automated workflow you can do
up to 96 wells 96 samples
it's going to be in a microplate but
you're using it on the assay map bravo
the bravo is going to be able to work
all
through all the different protocols on
its own you don't have to sit there with
it it can
do all the work as needed unattended
so it really frees you up to be able to
do more work
outside of babysitting the protocols
but you're actually going to be able to
purify your antibody
you would be able to denature and
immobilize and then you would digest
within glyconase you would take off your
fluorescent label
you would label it clean it up and be
able to elude it so that
then you'll be able to have your reading
to go forward
with the glycoprep there are several
different options you can use
instant a b instant pc 2ab
or apts and we have each of these
available in the glycopro protocols that
are
on the assay map bravo
the nice thing about it is part of the
workflow that we have
this is an example of one of the
glycoprep protocols
but we actually have it as kind of
combined into a nice
little workflow
gui interface so you could do your
affinity purification
you could do your normalization and then
you could choose
which glycan label you would like to use
you see the different ones that are
listed there
and we also have all those utilities
that you might need to use before
or after but in one gui interface
with the user you're able to click on
everything that you would need to do to
do your full glycoprep
type of approval
so hopefully i've been able to convey to
you today
that the essay map bravo will provide
great reproducibility for your entire
workflow
many times multiple steps in a workflow
the
the variability just increases and it's
compounded throughout the entire
workflow
we've been able to show that that is not
the case with assay matt bravo because
everything is so tight and we're able to
have
very tight reproducibility throughout
the entire workflow even though there
can be multiple steps
you can reduce the number of replicates
so you can really
increase the throughput that you can get
through your samples
you can increase your walk away time so
you can have more time to do more
there's never enough time in the day and
i know that there's a lot of folks that
need to be writing grants
they need to be analyzing data they need
to be preparing for their next
project there's so many more things that
you need to be doing
than just holding a handheld pipettor in
your hand
and adding reagents the assaymap bravo
will allow for you to do that
and so much more just based on the wide
range
of applications that are available
very easy to use software so you
able to look at it and be able just to
add a few parameters
and be able to click the green button
that tells it to go
it's really designed for non-automation
experts so you don't have to be an
automation engineer to know how to
program it
or how to make changes in the programs
everything is already prepared you just
have to fill in a few numbers
minimal training simple person to person
or site to site transfers
and it is a single platform for various
sample prep needs it's definitely not a
one-trick pony
you can do many many different things
with the assay map bravo
just a little um a fun story i want to
kind of leave you with
i i know that listening to someone say
oh it's
so easy to use it's so easy to use a
real live example is
i was working with some researchers in a
lab doing a demo with them
and we spent the first day me running
the ship if you will and really teaching
them how to use the
instrument the next day they came in and
said kenda i
really want to be able to run it myself
i said great i let them have control i
just stepped back if they had questions
of course i answered them
the third day that i was with them in
the lab they were bringing people from
down the hall
and showing them how to use the
instrument so it really is
that easy to be able to use and be able
to get
great results reproducible results and
reduce your variability
so that is what i wanted to share with
you guys today about the assay assaymat
bravo
how it's absolutely a scalable sample
prep and you're going to be able to get
very good precision for your proteomics
as well as your biopharmaceutical
analysis
thank you and i will now address any
questions if we have any
wonderful thank you dr evans for that
outstanding presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation
on the left of your screen you will see
a q a box please feel free to submit
your questions
through there for dr evans to answer for
you so
let's go ahead and it looks like we do
have one question
in here so far uh dr evans have there
been
any peer-reviewed publications regarding
the assay map bravo and
if so what journals were they in that's
a great question
um in fact we have been doing a tally of
some of our
journal articles just recently so that
we have a nice compendium
we have over a hundred and i think the
latest count was 103
peer-reviewed articles that have been
written
by our researchers in different journal
articles
most recently they've been published in
cell
nature and science so we've in you know
not too shabby type
of uh journals but also the journal of
proteomics uh
cell nature lots of different types of
journal articles have been recently
published using the assay map and
actually using the assay map bravo for
different
techniques that we hadn't even imagined
yet so it's great to see
the imagination of our researchers and
how they're utilizing
this tool to really get at those
questions they haven't been able to
answer before in their labs
wonderful so let's give the audience
just a couple more seconds to see if you
have any other questions
um your presentation was so informative
it answered everyone's questions dr
evans
of course so we'll go ahead and
and end with this so thank you again dr
evans and
thank you to the audience um for the
question again
it was such an informative presentation
nobody had any
um we hope you found today's
presentation to be informative
and insightful to our audience this
presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing
don't miss out on the other valuable
presentations on our agenda
please visit the event presentation
schedule in the auditorium
thank you again everyone for your
participation
stay healthy and until next time bye bye
thank you
you